se aplica a la propiedad distributiva a
faktor isarel maximo como divisor y
nos dicen 35 pero 50 es una palabra bastante
esto resistido en una boya de equipo de bloque
Los grados
vamos a verme en todos estos lugares
están pidiendo este pacto para usar el
máximo como divisor de 35 pero 50
quien es este emisor comun maximo de 35 y
50 y civil el excelente que tiene el más alto
que muestra 35 y 50
vemos que poder escribir 85 como cinco
veces si e tiene 50 puedes escribir como
cinco veces dijo 5 por siete y cinco por
día y se puede observar que cinco este
máximo emisor común de ambos ya que
city ​​y ellis en tiene pactor escom muniz
uno puede discriminar 3515 por 7 50
mirando y escribi 5 de s
obviamente esos están siendo filmados y año
en aras de la claridad vamos
responde los paréntesis a 1 cuando es
orden de operaciones dice que primero y
multiplicación de uno e igual intacto
período que notamos o claramente
acomodémonos un poco en cuanto yo
Quiero hacer estos factores al máximo como
un divisor y dijo es aquí que 65
y 75 que ya esta aqui y pronto ibas a ser tu
no está escrito soy y uso da
Propiedad distributiva
aquí estamos como dos juegos por vamos
saber usarlo que goiás e sacar fue
aquí y estas un kellogg aquí esto va a ser
igual a él cinco que si el máximo como
un divisor de ambos que es
multiplicando alice y tintin tenemos
aquí pero le dije a ips que tenemos aquí en
tonos ahora tenemos cinco lo que multiplica el
si y mas dias y somos legales
comprobemos pero viene la respuesta
esta chica el baston ejercita km y
entre 11 c y eso significa 35 más 50
los factores van a lo sumo como divisor
socio 5 estos como phishing mons
stacy y te pero ds5 esta maximo como un
divisor porque siete y vamos en el equipo en
factores comunes son primos relativos 35
a los 55 al igual que ustedes chicos temas días que vemos
muy bien ganamos otra ahora nos dicen
aplicar la propiedad distributiva a
actualizar max como divisor de 35
pero 14
así que si tenemos y nos enfrentaremos a ser
les hizo inútiles notas de biblioteca en tonos
y 35 y 14
me parece que tiene y tiene que
tos ferina y la tiene si es buena n
35 candidatos entre st
el primer elemento que multiplica a 55 y 14
entre ciudad estoy bien otra vez
el 5 y el 2 ni siquiera tienen factores comunes
recordemos al alcalde
hagamos lo máximo
esta vez tenemos 60 mas 44 y eso fue todo
parece que en 4 funciona
bebemos 4 60 entre 4 y si es igual a 15 de la
ego
vamos arriba es el resultado de 44 entre 4 y 11
claro porque 11 por 4 44 y 15 por 4 60
15 11
nota en factores comunes son exquisitas
activos vemos el yen